quand j'étais petit parce que moi aussi
j'étais petit quand j'étais petit je
regardais la télévision à l'époque sont
en noir et blanc
il y avait trois émissions que
j'adorerais par dessus tout et qui m'ont
beaucoup influencé finalement il y avait
dit mme dam dom daisy de galard il y
avait les raisins verts de chant
christophe averty et l'émission de
benjamin castaldi l'émission de benjamin
castaldi qui s'appelle c'est que ça fait
déjà célébrités non il y avait une autre
émission qui s'appelait un égal 3
c'était jacques martin et jean yanne
ah oui la grèce fait de bouche avec les
faut rendre hommage à un matin parce que
c'est une émission que lui avait eu
c'était sûrement là c'est à lui qu'on
avait demandé bon et c'est lui qui me
fait me dire eh ben il a eu raison parce
que c'est vachement ruant vers un bout
tout à l'heure vous ai vu le nombre de
fiches que j'ai sur vous c'est
incroyable jamais autant de fiches sur
canal ne sont pas un livre vous n'êtes
pas sortir bien alors on va commencer
tout de suite par la promo comme ça sera
fait 1
alors attention c'est comment on fait
hacker petites mains comme les
sourds-muets câble de soi qu'il
commençait pas avec les sourds du rc
duplain demand son nouvel changé après
la montée ce que vous voulez bien sûr
surtout vous attention 1 2 3 ben si bien
bien alors donc jorian vous publiez un
bouquin qui s'appelle le dictionnaire
des mots qui a que moi qui les connaît
déjà le titre vachement bien c'est chez
plon cdm ou que vous avez inventé vous
un représente page 25
non mais j'ai noté comme ça quelques
soins qui vont bien ferrer 25 à baluch
riz par exemple alors une baluch free
c'est une phrase stupide exemple la
démocratie s'arrête où commence la
raison d'état c'est qui ces deux places
couramment il ya phrase ou le sait ce
que c'est une phrase ou leur nom oui
j'ai lu attentivement le livre de jean
qui est un maître que je vénère comme en
lice al bataoui c'est vrai que c'est la
deuxième fois que je vois respectueux
pour quelques uns des dieux vivants pour
moi
donc continuez comme ça ça dans ce cas
on voit déjà les chandeliers les mecs
qui arrivent et noir sapin ça s'en va
une décrue ouais c'est le demande tout
le temps si à la fin il n'y a pas un qui
va prendre même super g je serais vous
je m'inquiéterais génial je t'admire et
même quand tu étais jeune donc rien à
voir avec la mort alors une phrase où
les vaches certes une phrase houle c'est
un vampire se nourrissant uniquement du
sang de jeunes filles vierges et dont
l'espèce a complètement disparu pour
cette raison évidemment c'est une phrase
houle alors après j'en ai encore ah oui
j'en ai un qui est drôle s'inclut mieux
plutôt mou et pas très net
c'est bien ce que ça veut dire le
travail effectué par madame cresson
pendant son séjour à la commission de
bruxelles et à lui trotter stablement gu
assez que les opérations dmo donc cédé
manque de les inventer oui mais c'est
les mots que j'ai inventé après la
définition
ah oui c'est ça sert vous allez
commencer je vais pas commencer à
prendre définit un point des mots puis à
chercher ce que ça voulait dire j'ai
fait des définitions puis après j'ai
cherché quétaine mots qui correspondent
le plus à ça alors par exemple il ya
outre l'opel larricq lopez c'est une
réunion de personnalités désignées par
l'état pourrait assumer dans le jeu
visuel des fonctions bien au dessus de
leurs compétences ce qui gêne
considérablement le travail du sont
qualifiés alors vice personnes et dames
enfin c'est assez on voit tout de suite
de qui il s'agit i gr big aussi alors
higueras dick bon à rien granic de tout
le service public la télévision
française peut se vanter de posséder le
plus grand nombre d'y graver hic si vous
voulez ya un fond de vérité tout les
toutes les dix ou quinze définition il y
en a une de bonne
c'est des mots qui risque d'être d'être
employé ça j'espère qu'ils vont être
employés
ça n'est jamais arrivé de faire quoi que
ce soit qui ne soit repris un jour ou
l'autre par un homme politique on nous
avait dit tout le monde il est beau tout
le monde il est gentil
et il y avait comme ça il ya des tas de
trucs qui sont entrées dans le bar il
est interdit d'interdire quand même
genre yann a inventé en 68 tout le monde
croit que c'est des étudiants du
quartier latin qui l'ont inventé c'est
vous qui l'avez inventé un matin sur rtl
il y il est interdit d'interdire qui est
devenu un tout le monde croit que ça a
été fait par des étudiants gauchistes
six mois qu'il ya des gens comme vous
qui rétablisse la vérité qui agit la
porte
ça m'a coûté assez cher les crs ss et de
toi crs scrs et c'est pas de moi moi
j'ai inventé le peuple aura ta peau sur
les pavés les frites non non dieu est
grand allah et au centime alors ses
débuts dit que c'est un dictionnaire qui
contrairement aux autres puissent être
ouverts n'importe quelle page pour y
trouver ce qu'on cherche pas oui parce
qu'il a été écrit comme ça
ouais à partir du moment où united écrit
il sans sans plan et au fur et à mesure
j'ai fait dans des endroits où je
pouvais pas écrire des choses très très
compliqué j'avais seulement des petites
fiches et j'écrivais les petites notes
pour moi des fois j'ai éclaté de rire
j'étais content de m'en trouver une
bonne alors j'étais content et je pense
que les gens doivent le lire comme ça et
les l'idéal
c'est de le mettre dans les toilettes en
amis vous avez fait ce que tout le monde
va faire un service qui a été écrit dans
l'est dans les avions effectivement je
voyageais beaucoup en fait non quand
vous dites à un moment page 79 les
toilettes des avions d'air france sont
abyss conique
c'est à dire quoi vit ce qu'une salle
salle voilà depuis une façon générale
tout ce qui est sur un air france est
raté alors il ya les toilettes qui sont
mal nettoyé les hôtesses de l'air qui
sont des grands mères volantes et et les
plateaux repas de son abouchahla
vraiment qu également annoncé auprès de
te faire surclasser nom faisait le goût
du voyage vous c'est marrant c'est un
truc c'est vraiment votre passion oui
oui mais vous dites ya une sensation
extraordinaire c'est dans un avion
finalement pire moment il ya le pilote
qui lie la botte droite c'est le mont
kenya votre gauche c'est l'humoriste
doit il se présente je suis dit je
regarde toujours moi les juge pas du
tout blasé je regarde toujours par la
bande à part le hublot ce qui est tout à
fait formels de placer orthez que tu
regardes plus il y en a une ou deux
se défendent pas pour les attaques tenir
là c'est joey starr il y avait dans le
temps avec les ailes d'air france une
espèce de d'habitude la carte assiette
de joutes sur les lignes brésilienne
maintenance et a saisi les franchises se
demande si c'est pas le 6 eur puis à
l'elysée